questions et aucune réponse.
- Vraiment un cauchemar.
Ça a été... incroyable.
- Elle n'y croyait presque plus.
Après 40 heures d'attente,
Cindy Charland tient enfin
les passeports de ses enfants
entre ses mains. Le départ
est prévu demain, à 7 h.
CINDY CHARLAND
- C'était pas facile du tout
parce que, dans le fond, on
attend ici de jouer, de soir et
de nuit. Je peux vous dire que
maintenant, c'est la joie.
Ils peuvent quitter.
- C'est  sorte la file
d'attente de la dernière chance.
Ces gens espèrent tous réussir
à monter à bord de leur avion
dans les prochaines heures.
- C'est très frustrant commtrane
situation, on a fait notre
demande début avril, fait
que ça fait deux mois
et demi, pas de nouvelles.
Notre voyage est demain.
- Ils n'acceptent personne au-
delà de 48 heures. La semaine
dernière, je suis venu, je leur
ai expliqué la situation pour
cette semaine, et ils m'ont
juste demander de rebrousser
chemin. Ils font ça
à tout le monde.
(brouhaha)
- À l'intérieur du complexe
Guy-Favreau, l'impatience
se fait de plus en plus sentir.
Des policiers ont été appelés
en renfort pour assurer l'ordre.
La situation est loin d'être
unique. Des gens attendent aussi
aux bureaux de Toronto,
de Vancouver et de Laval,
notamment, le jour, mais aussi
la nuit. La pressi La pressi Lae
sur le gouvernement Trudeau.
- La moitié de nos impôts va au
gouvernement fédéral, donc c'est
pas normal que les services
soient aussi dysfontionnels.
Je comprends qu'il y a de la
pression, que c'est difficile
des fois, qu'il y a de la rareté
de main-d'oeuvre.
JUSTIN TRUDEAU,
premier ministre du Canada
- On comprend que les gens
font face à des délais
inaceptables, une situation
extrêmement difficile,
mais nous continuons
notre travail tous les jours.
KARINA GOULD,
ministre fédérale de la Famide e
- Les gens sont en train de
traviller 12, 14, 16 heures déjà
et ils ont besoin
du temps pour procéder
les informations.
- Mais pour les députés
de l'opposition, ce n'est pas
suffisant.
ALAIN THERRIEN, leader
parlementaire, Bloc québécois
- On demande pas d'aller danser
sur la lune, on demande
de délivrer des passeports
avec
- Le gouvernement fédéral
veut embaucher 600 personnes
pour accélérer le traitement
des demandes. Des ressources
pourraient être réaffectées.
Des discussions sont en coursav.
Ici Kim Vermette,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.